because if there's a ghost all right you
know what i mean i don't want the upper
half wait a minute
my [ __ ] houses there'll be there'll
be some ghosts my house is haunted all
right yeah
but you have a haunted house george oh
yeah i i've had somebody come that's
another
hey so no no did you guys don't you
don't don't don't you can't just go
or bro
it's our favorite genre wait so right
now the house you're living in right now
is haunted
i had somebody come and clean it i'll
show you
when i when i moved in there was noise
and i thought
that's an old house and then i heard ma
and i [ __ ] shot up and i said
somebody i said someone's in here
i could go downstairs with a gun
nobody's around then you hear
noise on the other side of the the house
for years
and you hear it and you're like okay you
kind of make
peace with it you know you're like all
right you know and then people come over
and they're like
hey man i i went into your kitchen to
grab that stuff you asked me to grab and
when i
i [ __ ] could feel somebody behind me
he goes i thought it was the driver when
i looked back there wasn't anybody there
so i [ __ ] ran out of your house
or the or or somebody will say
they came to do one of these like door
dash kind of promos yeah
and the lady was doing the sound and she
told the person that was with me
she says tell george that i hear
somebody talking oh
so if you can ask them to be quiet and
there was i said there's nobody here and
the lady
[ __ ] saw somebody [ __ ] walk by and
then it
i'm going to show you this picture and
then um
i'm not ready i got it i got to say i'll
show you a video but i'm gonna show you
this picture
so whatever you do
don't don't if
listen if anybody has a [ __ ] ouija
board throw that [ __ ]
away today well you did ouija in that
house
black man no no no but this black magic
ouija board it's funny you could get one
at [ __ ] cbs target yeah it's [ __ ]
black magic man don't [ __ ] with
because you're calling people that are
haven't gotten to where they belong yeah
i know i've seen the movies bro
you don't remember when i saw the
exorcist bro where the [ __ ] exorcist
says hey father you have any change for
a catholic
they if they will if you're calling your
father
a [ __ ] demon will take his voice oh
and say it's you know it's me
but it's a [ __ ] demon so careful who
you call
because those [ __ ] will i don't
[ __ ] around either no they'll come and
they won't go away
george i have one question for you you
are a um
relatively wealthy man why the [ __ ] are
you still there [ __ ] move
yeah i know you know no [ __ ] move
okay let me tell you this story let me
tell you this
so you know i always wanted to live in
los feliz right so
i fell out of escrow on a house i was up
there and then
you know we're driving this guy's
driving it's like two hours i'm [ __ ]
you know because i
was working in santa monica and i looked
on trulia and there's a house
perfect [ __ ] those feelings like a
perfect house and you go oh my god
call this lady i said hey brooke can you
get me in there she calls she goes
tomorrow we're in there at one o'clock
i said nothing earlier no she goes
george they have it like every 15
minutes
with a 15-minute break like everybody
wants this house so i said oh [ __ ] then
why even go she goes hey you just go
look
so i go in there beautiful pool thing
that's in there
then you go upstairs come down the guy
goes what do you think and i said
dog it's great and he goes you want it i
said what do you mean do i want it like
what about all these [ __ ] goes i'll
call the guys
that owner call the owner he's a doctor
he goes he's a huge fan of yours so i
said hey guess who's in your house
and he said oh [ __ ] george he goes
hey tell him if he gives me the full
price
he can have it and there's like 50
[ __ ] offers wow
so i i paid the full price and i got it
and then you know you do some work to it
and in the fireplace
so my name is george because of i was
born
on april 23rd and at the general
hospital over there
my mom wanted to name me anastasio who
they thought
my father was on my grandmother's life
[ __ ] him you're not naming that
[ __ ] somebody that disappeared
so my grandmother goes what's today
tells a nurse what's today
april 20 what's a day it's saint
george's day
so she goes george edward say george
and i told the dude that i
uh the contractor i said hey man can you
[ __ ] clean those fireplaces out
because they look like they haven't been
cleaned in forever
and when he calls me back he goes hey
when you get home look in the fireplace
because there's a conquistador tile in
there
and it's a title of st george from the
1920s
so you almost feel like it's i mean you
know it's not saint christopher
it's not you know the being of waterloo
it's a [ __ ] saint george style
from the 20s so
i made the mistake of calling people
especially one who had just recently
passed and that's when a lot of the
activity came a lot of the banging
and a lot of the orbs and a lot of the
[ __ ] but then
it was in the hallway i'll show you a
[ __ ] video
there's a [ __ ] person in the
reflection of a picture
that's moving in the thing oh my god but
i took up i took a picture like i felt
here's you can see kind of a shadow i'm
i'm gonna show it to you
but you can see the shadow okay so when
i'm in bed now all of a sudden
all of a sudden there's more things
happening more
you know like you just you're like
[ __ ] god
i feel like [ __ ] somebody's over
there so now it started to happen on the
right side of the
with the bathrooms over there and i
would go like this
and i'm like so i took a video of that
right side of my bedroom
and i didn't see any orbs or anything
but in the picture
not a mirror in the picture i see the
square
and i go what the [ __ ] is that and then
i i
pulled it open and it's a
[ __ ] green face
oh my god
oh my god oh my god
oh my god it's a green face
and i said i said [ __ ] this i said
i hired this lady to come and [ __ ]
take him out and she did
how was she um would you say he got the
green guy
she don't know they don't they know
[ __ ] yeah ghosts
hey the green guy's gone the [ __ ]
dude hanging out
the mist is gone yeah yeah there was
some crazy i have questions
yeah now did we did we do the cleansing
in
the hippie way or the catholic way
um i think no i think they did it the
hippie way
with the sage because that [ __ ] don't
work you got to [ __ ] it
on their way but no no listen i know
they're on their way
but but but when you see that
you're you're like i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah you guys the only reason i'm
telling you this is because when i was
younger my dad's boat had to be
exercised like they had
my dad was agnostic he didn't believe in
[ __ ] but it turns out like they had like
a haunted steering wheel in his ship
so they there was a family of five
living there and the priest
had to exercise it and the next day the
priest died
okay wait the actually does this have a
peacock
and then when my dad like went through a
depression he grew his beard out and he
slept on the couch for like six months
and he wouldn't speak to us for six
months what i'm saying is this [ __ ] is
real
no i know i believe in this [ __ ] and it
freaks me out and i want to make sure
that not some like young hippie
with some sage i get it i get it yeah
yeah but for right now they're gone but
but also
[ __ ] move bro but also but also when
you have
things of other people like i have
things that belong to people who
were famous part of their [ __ ] spirit
and their energy is with those things
even things that are just collected from
people
they you know you see a robe and you're
like man that [ __ ] robe is my dad
like i just he wants to wear this robe
and you have the robe you have part of
his energy
his self in there you know you leave
things that's why you know when someone
dies and you
you know everybody's sad and then they
go look what he left and you look at
something that belonged to him and you
[ __ ] just
you're destroyed because that's them
their essence is their essence that's
them that's what they
like that's what they did do you feel as
though these people are these entities
living there were they
of the um um friendly variety
you know in the beginning but then
in the last six months i called somebody
spirit and they [ __ ] showed up i'm
telling you and and
since that time it's been it's been
more like i'm like what the [ __ ] was
that and then that that [ __ ]
and the [ __ ] orbs and the name words
and the [ __ ] mist in the hallway and
the middle of the night
you're just like this is [ __ ] insane
and
i just i just had enough like you know
in the video i saw something that i
that i didn't see before and when i saw
that
i said this is this this is [ __ ] way
past
anybody's [ __ ] tolerance level like
there's a there's a person
in the reflection of this picture that's
wearing white that's mo
that's moving and i'm like that
that [ __ ] man that's it i didn't want
you could have been your girlfriend or
something
no
no no it's a [ __ ] thing and the thing
is not a mirror it's a picture it's a
picture like this is not
this is not a mirror it's a picture so
that [ __ ] face leaning in like this
yeah yeah that's you know they go hey
jordan that's not a fake [ __ ]
that's a [ __ ]
no anybody that sees that's gonna be
like that's a [ __ ] face yeah i saw
faith so now you go okay
but for for whatever anybody believes
in that house it's from the 20s and [ __ ]
like you know so yeah yeah yeah yeah
and it feels it it feels different it
feels different
unsettling but but of course i'm sure
it's going to be a process but
yeah all that all of that [ __ ] that that
you know
and i live alone it's a big [ __ ]
house and you hear these [ __ ] noises
man you're just like
it's and i you know when it's funny as a
kid i was afraid of everything afraid of
the dark and all that [ __ ]
but you think as an adult i'm almost 69
all that's gone away everything that
and also for that kid that like when you
start to believe in yourself and believe
your
your worth and believe that that
regardless of
you know somebody you know hey listen
[ __ ] videos you know
and then you go take a shower you're
brand new again
when you get to as long as you have a
[ __ ] life you have a chance to
[ __ ] change everything
right even there are 50 loads you know
yeah yeah but you do have a so as long
as like you know kids that are depressed
and also
there there's there's opportunity to be
better when you're alive you know
it's over but you know uh um and so
all the [ __ ] that i had as a kid is gone
like all the things that scared me all
all the insecurities that i had yeah are
are gone wishing people like a
buddhist you know practice buddhism and
that came from like just seeing the
signs man of like
there was a buddhist temple in san
fernando and my grandmother would see
him and at the same time like harry
christians buddhist
you know they don't want anything my
grandmother go she goes
i should grab their buddhists
they don't want any the buddhists don't
want anything she's like everybody wants
something
and you just hear that [ __ ] voice
every day
and then i moved to sherman oaks it was
a buddhist temple of the corner
i bought a place in hawaii so [ __ ]
top of the hill would get there to go
get something to eat [ __ ] buddhist
temple there
so in at the dark time of like the
divorce and all that [ __ ] that you still
have to go work and
you go home and you're alone [ __ ]
brutal man
taking some [ __ ] vicodins and a
[ __ ] four locos listen you don't need
[ __ ] bike anyway you drinking a four
local
those [ __ ] thank god that'll
make a baby let's go find them yeah yeah
some people should they give me some
cesar for christmas like
if you want to if you want to kill
yourself there's way but you know what i
didn't want to [ __ ] go out like that
like i
you know and then i started to look at
the principles of like
not wishing anybody harm and you know of
of
of trying to just be better and boy you
know and it just
and i went and met the dalai lama in
boston i [ __ ] went over there and
shook my hand and we talked and spoke at
his 80th birthday party like five years
ago and stayed
connected and it's changed it's changed
everything about me man like i i don't
trip off anything
wow and i'm happy to be alive and even
all that [ __ ] that's that would that
would be like
that yeah there's a [ __ ] mexican
stand in the middle of the street
i don't know yelling something like that
open like i can handle that [ __ ]
why yeah because i've i've already
seen [ __ ] different variations of my
life that's why you can handle ghosts
yeah and i understand them like i don't
but i won't but i won't [ __ ] call
them anymore like don't call them yeah
yeah
cause they'll come real quick um
because i know i remember when brock you
know i mean it was
uh inaugurated right you went yep
i remember watching that going it was
you there was like a bunch of guys but
like sam jackson
wow this is cool right what when you
were